[Music]
i'll read you the rules okay maybe
you'll find them interesting
tell the truth
[Music]
do not do things that you hate
which i think is a variant of telling
the truth because you have to act out
the truth as well as
telling it
act so that you can tell the truth about
how you act that's obviously related to
the first two pursue what is meaningful
not what is expedient
if you have to choose be the one who
does things
instead of the one who is seen to do
things
pay attention
assume that the person you are listening
to might know something you need to
know listen to them hard enough so that
they will share it with you
plan and work diligently to maintain the
romance in your relationships
be careful who you share good news with
be careful who you share bad news with
make at least one thing better every
single place you go
imagine who you could be and then aim
single-mindedly at that
do not allow yourself to become arrogant
or resentful
try to make one room in your house as
beautiful as possible
[Music]
compare yourself to who you were
yesterday not to who someone else is
today
work as hard as you possibly can on at
least one thing and see what happens
if old memories still make you cry write
them down carefully and completely
maintain your connections with people
do not carelessly denigrate social
institutions or artistic achievement
treat yourself as if you were someone
that you are responsible for helping
ask someone to do you a small favor so
that he or she can ask you to do one in
the future
make friends with people who want the
best for you
do not try to rescue someone who does
not want to be rescued and be very
careful about rescuing someone who does
nothing well done is insignificant
set your house in perfect order before
you criticize the world
dress like the person you want to be
be precise in your speech
stand up straight with your shoulders
back
don't avoid something frightening if it
stands in your way and don't do
unnecessarily dangerous things
do not let your children do anything
that makes you dislike them
do not transform your wife into a maid
do not hide unwanted things in the fog
notice that opportunity lurks where
responsibility has been abdicated
read something written by someone great
pet a cat when you encounter one on the
street
don't bother children when they're
skateboarding
don't let bullies get away with it
[Music]
write a letter to the government if you
see something that needs fixing and
propose a solution
remember that what you do not yet know
is more important than what you already
know
and be grateful in spite of your
suffering